we now come to the leader of the
opposition kirsten
[Applause]
can i start by saying to the prime
minister
that i do know that the relationship
between a prime minister and leader of
the opposition
is never easy
and this one's proved no exception to
the rule
but i would like to take this
opportunity to wish him his wife and his
family the best for the future
can i also put on record our gratitude
to the fire and rescue services for all
their courageous work yesterday in
extreme temperatures
all our thoughts are with those affected
by the fires particularly those that
have lost their homes
i joined the prime minister in his
comments about the bombings in hyde park
and the ira warmings
i also join him in his comments about
the lionesses the coverage starts at 7
30 tonight on bbc one and i'm sure the
whole country will be roaring them on
and for anyone who doesn't fancy
football eastenders is on
so if you'd rather watch outrageous
characters taking lumps out of it
themselves
you've got a choice albert square or the
tory leadership debates on catch up
on that topic mr speaker
why
why does the prime minister think
that those vying to replace him decided
to pull out of the sky debate last night
[Applause]
well
mr speaker
i i i i'm not following this thing
particularly closely but my
my my my impression my impression is
that there's been a quite a lot of
debate already and i think the public i
think the public are having they're
having an ample opportunity to view the
talent uh mr speaker that
anyone of any one of which any one of
which will as i say before like some
household detergent would wipe the floor
[Applause]
today's happens to be just about the
anniversary of the exit from lockdown
last year and do you remember do you
remember what he said uh he said yeah
i'm gonna remind him he said it was
reckless it was because we were able to
take that decision mr speaker supported
by every single one of those
conservative candidates opposed by him
that we had the fastest economic growth
in the g7 we're now able to help
families up and down the country if we
listen to him it wouldn't have been
possible mr speaker and i don't think
they'll be listening to him either
yes
well i'm impressed you managed to get
through that with a straight face
actually
um i think the truth is this
they organize the tv debates because
they thought it'd be a great chance for
the public to hear from the candidates
first hand yeah then disaster struck
because the public actually heard from
the candidates firsthand
but i am interested
in what he makes of the battle for his
job so let me start with a simple one
does the prime minister agree with his
former chancellor that plans put forward
by the other candidates are in his words
i've got them here nothing more than the
fantasy economics of unfunded spending
promises
[Applause]
[Music]
to speak they know all about fantasy
economics because
they've committed already they've
already committed to 94 billion pounds
of extra taxes and spending uh mr
speaker which every household in this
country would have to pay for to the
tune of about 2 100 pounds it's thanks
to the uh the former chancellor's
management of the economy thanks
discovers management of the economy we
had growth in may of north point i don't
make 0.5
we have more people
in paid employment than any time in the
history of this country mr speaker and i
leave i'm i'm proud to be leaving office
right now with unemployment at or near a
50 year low
when they left office it was at 8 that's
the difference between them and us
mr speaker
every labour pledge made under my
leadership is fully costed those buying
those buying to protect him
they
mr speaker
those vying to replace him have racked
up
330 billion pounds of unfunded spending
commitments
but i do know that the prime minister
didn't agree with his former chancellor
so what about his foreign secretary
she was withering about the government's
economic record
she said again her words here they are
if rishi has got this great plan for
growth
why haven't we seen it in the last two
and a half years at the treasury
that's a fair question is it prime
minister
mr speaker i think that everybody would
uh agree that what you saw in the last
two and a half years was because of the
pandemic the biggest fall in output uh
biggest fall in output for 300 years
which this government dealt with and
cope with magnificently
by distributing vaccines faster than any
other european government faster than
any other major economy which would not
have been possible if we had listened to
him and that's why mr speaker we have
the fiscal fire power that is necessary
to help families up and down the country
making tax cuts for virtually everybody
paying national insurance contributions
the the difference between
labor and the conservative speaker is a
crucial philosophical difference under
labour families on low incomes get most
of their income from benefits under us
they get most of it from earnings
because we believe jobs jobs jobs that's
the difference mr speaker
[Applause]
mr speaker inflation is up again this
morning and millions are struggling with
the cost of living crisis and he he's
decided to come down from his gold
wallpapered bunker for one last time
to tell us
that everything's fine i am going to
miss the delusion
but his foreign secretary didn't stop
there mr speaker she also said that the
former chancellor's 15 tax rises are
leading the country into recession
and the member for portsmouth north was
even more scathing
she said again her words
our public services are in a desperate
state
we can't continue with what we've been
doing because it clearly isn't
working has the prime minister told her
who's been running our public services
for the last 12 years
mr speaker this is absolutely again he's
doing this completely satirical this is
the government this is the government
that is investing
650 billion pounds uh in infrastructure
in skills in technology he talks about
public services what really matters to
people this country right now is getting
there getting their appointments getting
their operations fixing the code with
backlogs that's what we're doing fixing
the ambulances that's what he should be
talking about mr speaker and that's why
we voted through that's why we passed
the 39 billion pound health and care
levy mr speaker which they
opposed every time something needs to be
done mr speaker they try to oppose it
because there's a great pointless human
bollard mr speaker that's what he is
mr speaker
if only if only it was satirical
it's what the future candidates think of
is mr speaker
[Applause]
we want to get through pmq's because
there's quite a few of you wanting to
catch my eye it will be what help will
get through in order to do that kirsten
i appreciate they may not want to hear
what their future leader thinks of their
record in government but i think the
country needs to know if only it were
satirical prime minister it's what the
candidates think of the record yeah but
among the mudslinging there was one very
important point because the member for
safran walden claimed that she warned
the former chancellor that he was
handing taxpayer money directly to
fraudsters in covid loans
she says
he dismissed her worries
and that as a result he cost the
taxpayer 17 billion pounds
does the prime minister think that she's
telling the truth
okay well this is the one of the last
blasts from captain hindsight and mr
speaker because uh at least at least to
me at least to me because because they
were the party i remember they were the
party who was who are so so desperate uh
for us to be uh hiring their friends
with to get to with ppe they wanted a
football agent uh to supply a theatrical
costumia uh to supply ppe do you
remember mr speaker we had we had to get
that stuff at record speed uh we
produced 408 billion pounds worth of
support for families and for businesses
up and down the country mr speaker and
the only reason we were able to do it at
such speed it's because we've managed
the economy in a sensible and moderate
way and labor every time they've left
office it's with unemployment higher
they're economically illiterate mr
speaker and they would wreck the economy
i think the message coming out of this
leadership contest is pretty clear they
got us into this mess and they've no
idea how to get us out of it
the foreign secretary says we can't go
on with our current economic policy
the member for portsmouth north bemoaned
the fact that what we've been doing has
not been good enough
and the member for safran walden
probably puts it best when she simply
asked why should the public trust us we
haven't exactly covered ourselves in
glory their words
their future leaders words
they've trashed every part of their
record in government from dental care
and ambulance response times to the
highest taxes in 70 years
what message does it send when the
candidates be prime minister can't find
a single decent thing to say about him
about each other or their record in
government
mr speaker
what does it say what does he what does
he say about him that no one can name a
single policy of the late after three
years of the labour opposition apart
from putting up tatters he's one of
those pointless plastic bollards you
find uh
around around a deserted road works on a
motorway mr speaker we got brexit done
he voted against it 48 times we got this
country far side of kobe in spite of
everything uh he would have kept and
when he would have kept us in long time
we're fixing social care mr speaker when
they have no plan and no ideas of their
own and we're now bringing forward
measures
with in the face of strikes to outlaw
wildcat strikes mr speaker uh i can tell
you to outlaw wildcat strikes i can tell
you why i can tell you why he does that
that funny wooden flapping gesture i'll
tell you why he does have funny wooden
fabric because mr speaker he's got he's
uh he's got the union barons pulling his
strings from beneath him
that's the truth a hundred million
pounds mr speaker
we've restored our democracy and our
independence
we've got this country through covid and
i'm proud to say that when it comes to
tackling climate change or sticking up
for ukraine we have led the world on the
international stage and i want to thank
my friends and colleagues on these
benches for everything that they have
done